[Music]
coming up on fyi we've got a right royal
celebration for the queen's platinum
jubilee
[Music]
we'll be doing some digging into
britain's longest reigning monarch
and i'm checking out a new coin that's
been made to celebrate the queen 70
years on the throne
[Music]
welcome to fyi the show where you get
your say and all the latest info yeah
and this week we've got all the info
about her majesty queen elizabeth ii
who's commemorating her platinum jubilee
which means that she's been on the
throne for 70 years
the whole country has been marking her
platinum jubilee with a long weekend of
celebrations
it kicked off with an event called
trooping the color to mark the queen's
official birthday the queen's grandson
prince william also took part in the
parade outside buckingham palace
the queen has two birthdays doesn't she
so her actual birthday is in april but
it's too chilly for the parade then so
she has it in june instead all right for
some i'd love two birthdays yeah same
well we've been researching and there's
loads of great facts about the queen
like i love how she owns all the swans
in england because historically they
were a delicacy to eat at feasts and
banquets so only monarchs and a select
few others were allowed to own them it's
illegal to hunt and eat them now though
i read that apparently the queen doesn't
like to serve spaghetti at state
banquets because it's hard for guests to
eat and she doesn't want to embarrass
them fair enough
sometimes it's difficult to know whether
everything you read about the queen is
true or not though so we found a couple
more stories but can you tell which is
fake and which is fact
[Music]
is it true that over the years the queen
only faces to the right on coins simply
because her father king george vi
faced to the left
apparently it's been a tradition for 300
years where each king or queen faces in
a different direction to the monarch
before them
or is it true that you can tell when the
queen is home at buckingham palace when
the union flag is raised on the roof
fake or fact we'll tell you later
[Music]
another common story you might hear
about the queen is that even though
she's the ruler of great britain that
she actually has no power at all but is
that true well the government also has
power over the country so it makes you
wonder who exactly is in charge but if
you don't get it stay with us braden's
been investigating
it's time to play who's the boss
here's a simple question with not such a
simple answer who is the boss of the
united kingdom is it the prime minister
the head of the united nations or the
british monarch
well they're all really important but
the official answer is
the british monarch who can either be a
queen or a king
at the moment of course we have the
queen
in the uk the monarch is also the head
of state which basically means they are
the most important leader in the country
but confusingly that doesn't mean they
hold the most power
i'm going to need a bit of help getting
my head around this and i know just the
person
hello brayden hello so how much power
does the british monarch actually have
well the monarch is a really important
figurehead here in the uk in fact i'd go
as far as to say that the monarch is
probably one of the best known people
around the world but actually when it
comes to things like making laws then
she doesn't have that many powers
it is largely a ceremonial role so what
else does the monarch do
well it's a really busy role for example
the monarch every week has a private
meeting with the prime minister but it's
not the monarch's responsibility to tell
the prime minister what to do they are
there to advise encourage and toward
they have that very important role as
well of giving out honours to people
who've been doing good work up and down
the country and carrying out visits to
shine a light on important community
projects now the monarch is also
commander in chief of the armed forces
but it doesn't mean it's their
responsibility to start wars that comes
down to the uk government which of
course is voted for by uk adults as part
of our democracy so am i right thinking
that the british monarch is the head of
state in some other countries
yes so this one does seem a little bit
weird but it all dates back to a time
when britain had control of other
countries around the world as part of
the british empire now as that fell
apart a body of nations called the
commonwealth was formed and actually
during her time the queen has been head
of state of 32 of those countries as
they've become independent though lots
of them haven't needed her anymore as
their queen however she is still head of
state of 15 countries lots of them that
you would have heard of so for example
canada australia and new zealand and
some overseas territories such as
gibraltar and the falkland islands
well thank you very much
okay so i get all of that but what i'm
really scratching my head about is how
all this royal family stuff even started
so i'm gonna take us back in time for a
quick history lesson
you've heard of 1066 right that was the
year the french invaded england in what
was called the norman conquest having
won the battle this guy william the
conqueror was made king of england even
though he could hardly speak any english
since then there have been loads of
battles over who has control of the
throne and some untimely deaths so lots
of different kings and queens some of my
favorites are richard ii who was only 10
when he was crowned imagine that
henry viii who had six wives and had two
of them killed
and elizabeth the first who fought off
an attempt to overthrow her when the
spanish armor sailed towards england
now let's look at our current queen
elizabeth ii believed to be a direct
descendant of william the conqueror this
was her coronation in 1953 if she began
the longest reign in the history of the
british monarchy so the rules are that
to become our head of state you have to
be born into the royal family and
there's a bit of a cue
when prince charles was born he took his
automatic place to be next in line to
the throne then it'll be his first born
child prince william and then william's
children prince george princess
charlotte and prince louis
you also have to be christian because
ever since the reign of henry viii part
of the role is to be the defender of the
faith
the british monarch is the supreme
governor of the church of england but
they also recognise and celebrate other
faiths
as for other countries well they all
have their own systems to decide who
becomes their head of state for example
in saudi arabia king salman bin abdul
aziz has absolute power and there's
never been a national election
and in countries like the usa brazil and
nigeria the head of state is the
president elected by the people with
power to run the country and make new
laws
the system here in the uk is not without
its critics who say it's outdated and
too expensive
but others argue that we really benefit
from having the monarchy
it allows the politicians to get on with
running the country without too many
distractions like touring other
countries to promote the uk
with so many fans of the royal family
and its history it also attracts
tourists from all around the world to
the uk bringing millions of pounds to
the economy and having a royal family
with all its traditions makes the uk
stand out in the world
for more i don't get it explainers on
big issues and complicated stories like
racism the food crisis and the war in
ukraine just head to our webpage first
dot news forward slash fyi
[Music]
remember max who was sleeping out in his
tent to raise money for charity
well he recently got awarded the british
empire medal which means he's been
recognized by the queen for his amazing
fundraising wow
he slept out in his tent every night for
two years and raised over 700 000 pounds
for the north devon hospice in honor of
his neighbor who was a patient there
he's still camping out in his tent but
has agreed to sleep inside if he and his
family go away or if it's really
terrible weather nice little max
[Music]
maya would you say that the queen has
the most recognizable face in the world
i think so i can't think of anybody else
that has a more recognizable face than
hers yeah i agree well thomas has been
given special access behind the scenes
in a place where they get to see her
majesty's face every day
this is the raw mint just outside of
cardiff in wales and if you're thinking
the raw mint is some kind of sweet shot
for the queen where they make mints
you're completely wrong let's have a
look inside
[Music]
ready yeah oh my gosh i was lucky to be
given access into the high security area
where money is made this isn't just any
button it's a button that releases newly
made coins
the raw mint is basically a factory
where they make our money in fact this
place makes 5 billion coins every year
not just for the uk but for about 60
other countries as well
that's a lot of dosh
if you've ever played heads or tails
you'll know that on one side of our
coins is the queen's head
and to celebrate the queen's platinum
jubilee they've just produced a new 50p
coin
so do you think this will end up in our
pockets to spend or is this a
collector's item to remember the queen's
platinum jubilee this would absolutely
be something i would be collecting i
always say a coin is worth whatever
someone's willing to pay for it yeah in
the past we've sold a coin with a face
value of a pound
for one million pounds wow exactly so
who knows what this could be worth in
the future but we know that the previous
longest reading morning queen victoria
her coins are very very collectible
this year the raw man is handing out 7
000 of the new 50p coins to any of us
who complete a junior forrester award
these guys from the school in martha
tidville have all been taking part in
the award scheme by planting trees for
the jubilee
and now they're here to collect their
couch
we had to do all the activities for it
and like accomplish stuff and we planted
trees because the queen likes trees we
need to plant trees so then for the
future generation that we can be more
healthy so what would you like to say to
the queen on a platinum jubilee well
done for being so enthusiastic with all
the trees and
thank you for taking care of our country
so congratulations to the queen honor 70
years on the throne and guys i'll see if
i can bring you back one of these
special 50p coins
nice one thomas and here we have the
special jubilee coin check it out maya
it's so cool i like that she's on a
horse she really likes horses doesn't
she oh and dogs especially her corgis
yeah and to mark her jubilee we wanted
to hear what an fyi news club thought of
the queen
over to the members of st michael's
school in high wickham
[Music]
you look so happy throughout all these
pictures yeah she looks so pretty though
she's a very like
staple and idolized figure she's one of
the longest reigning monarchs she is the
wrong she is she's exactly i mean
it's crazy though because we've had her
for like 70 years of rain and she's 96
years old that's we have to realize
that's a long that's a long period of
time 70 years on the throne she's so
dedicated yeah her dedication is like
incredible because she took over from um
her father i think yeah
george
do you think the queen's ever comes a
high wicker
actually i do have a faint memory of her
coming to my nursery i want to meet the
queen the queen reads even i want the
queen to come to my nursery that would
have been so cool people think that she
doesn't do anything but behind the
scenes she actually does like so much a
lot of countries especially like in
brazil people really admire the queen
she's been with us like through a lot of
things and i feel like she's definitely
still relevant as people look up to her
and she will never be irrelevant i would
also ask her to give me some wise words
of wisdom yeah i'd probably ask her like
yeah
how to therapy from the queen yeah
if i were to meet her i would ask what
um sports teams she supports if i were
to meet her i would just congratulate
her for serving us these 70 years and
doing a remarkable job
[Music]
thanks guys and in answer to your
question zane about which team the queen
supports we did some digging and it's
been rumored that she supports west ham
united and arsenal although she's never
confirmed that because she wants to
remain neutral i guess we'll never know
and if you want to have your say on an
issue right here on fyi head to our
webpage at first dot news forward slash
fyi you'll get all the info on how to
set up an fyi news club at your school
[Music]
so it's fact that the queen only faces
to the right on coins go ahead and check
for yourself you won't find her facing
left because that's the direction her
dad king george vi faced and each new
monarch just swaps direction it's that
simple
which means it's fake that the union
flag is what to look out for if the
queen is at home in buckingham palace or
any of her homes for that matter
confusingly the union flag actually
flies when the queen isn't there it's
actually this royal standard flag that
is flown when the queen is present so
look out for that next time you're
visiting one of the palaces
well that's about it from us and our
platinum jubilee special we're going to
leave you with some more festivities
from across the country and a huge
congratulations again to her majesty for
70 years on the throne see you next week
[Music]
you